a priori les avocats de patrick dils ont
marqué des points aujourd'hui nouvelle
enquête très méticuleuse de la
gendarmerie confirme les doutes sur
l'emploi du temps reste les aveux de
l'accusé est un sentiment toujours très
partagés audiences suivis par stéphanie
perez et salah grammy
à leur arrivée à la cour d'assises de
lyon les gendarmes de la section de
recherches de metz se font plutôt
discrets ils savent que leur rapport est
très attendu d'un ton assuré le
capitaine hans expose ses conclusions
les deux enfants ne donne plus signe de
vie à partir de 17h15 or patrick dils ne
pouvait être présent au moment du
meurtre
il semble résulter avec une quasi
certitude
qu'il était matériellement impossible
que patrick dils puis 7 sur les lieux du
crime à l'heure du crime puisque à ce
moment là il était encore et au plus tôt
à pont-à-mousson c'est à dire une ville
distante de près de 25 km2 ont une idée
mais
la cour est troublé par le travail
extrêmement rigoureux des gendarmes de
metz qui ont recoupé près de 200
témoignages et éléments d'enquêté mais
le doute subsiste encore et toujours le
capitaine ans le reconnaît lui même je
suis abasourdi par les aveux de patrick
dils et les parties civiles en profite
ces analyses arrive bien tard quinze ans
après les faits on connaît la fragilité
mais vraiment la fragilité les
témoignages fragilité de témoignages sur
des horaires je ne parle pas sur des
faits mais sur des horaires on peut
quand même se poser la question si
quinze ans plus tard un raisonnement
intellectuel de ce genre peut tenir la
route je pense qu'ils défendent une
thèse qui est celle notamment
d'impliquer rôle dans cette histoire
parce qu'ils ont peut-être l'impression
un sentiment selon les enquêteurs ce
double meurtre représentent en effet la
quasi signature criminelle de francis
heaulme que tueur en série a déjà nié à
huit reprises être le meurtrier des deux
petits garçons sa déposition demain est
très attendu s'il a les clés d'énigmes
les donnera-t-il c'est toute la question